la rabia se extendió por las calles de
catalunya incendios destrozos y choques
entre policía y manifestantes se
vivieron en barcelona y otras ciudades
de la región española en la capital
catalana una joven resultó gravemente
herida en un ojo el motivo de la
protesta la encarcelación del rapero
español pablo hasél
[Aplausos]
queremos no nos van a doblegar ni con
toda la represión
estas eran las palabras dejase el más
pronto el martes al ser detenido por la
policía en la universidad de lleida allí
se habían cerrado el lunes para
dificultar su arresto tras exceder el
viernes la fecha límite para entrar
voluntariamente en prisión el artista
deberá enfrentar nueve meses de cárcel
tras ser condenado por delitos de
enaltecimiento del terrorismo' e
injurias contra la corona y las
instituciones del estado español en sus
canciones no voy a permitir que me
dicten lo que tengo que pensar lo que
tengo que sentir lo que tengo que decir
lo que tengo que hacer la sentencia ha
generado un amplio debate en torno a la
llamada ley mordaza aprobada en 2015 por
el gobierno conservador de mariano rajoy
que supuso un recorte en las libertades
de los ciudadanos
wolves singh a west of all en primer
lugar creo que es un derecho expresar tu
opinión ya sea rapeando ya sea cantando
ya sea bailando ya sea haciendo lo que
creas claro la semana pasada más de 200
artistas firmaron un manifiesto en apoyo
a hasél de hecho españa fue el país con
más artistas encarcelados en 2019 por
delante de turquía e irán
una organización freemium